so if you read the headlines kind of
seems like the world is a terrible place
full of violence despair and war but it
turns out war is actually declining we
live in the most peaceful time in human
history there's lots of reasons why but
here's three of the biggest ones first
the spread of democracy around the world
international relations scholars have
found consistently the democracies don't
fight us with each other now why is that
true there might be plenty of reasons
but one big one is that people who live
in democracies and think it's wrong to
start wars with other democracies their
legitimate governments it's wrong to
attack them but there's a flip side to
them democracies do often fight force
with autocracies
luckily most of the world's countries
are democracies now so the Democratic
peace is probably making the world much
more peaceful second big reason why war
is declining is nuclear deterrence
nuclear weapons obviously big and scary
however nuclear deterrence may have
prevented a devastating war between the
United States and the Soviet Union
everyone recognized that they would lose
statistical evidence suggest that that
is true that is that most countries are
too scared of the consequences of
nuclear war to fight one there's a dark
side and not just the risk of global
annihilation from accident the country
gets nuclear weapons they feel rather
safer in being aggressive in little ways
you know small conflicts or bullying
around their non-nuclear neighbors this
weird paradox that nuclear weapons make
the world more violent and more peaceful
at the same time it's called the
stability instability paradox the third
reason that Wars decline has been the
spread of the idea of national
sovereignty this idea is hundreds of
years old
the idea that you shouldn't interfere
inside the borders of another state but
people didn't take the idea too
seriously
because stealing new land used to be a
major cause of war I think American
European colonialism or World War two
but after World War two nations pledged
to stop since 1976 there has been a
single successful war of conquest suffer
maybe Russia and Crimea really recently
began though sovereignty the flipside
sometimes governments go to war against
their own people and poor weak
government
often collapse into civil war
sovereignty makes it hard for the
international community intervened to
stop either of those kinds of wars but
on the whole when you see those terrible
headlines remember the world way better
off than it ever has been there's less
war and less violence than almost any
other time in human history
that's something we're celebrating